hey today we had the battle of the top
to us chess players and one of them is
with us fabiano caruana tell us a little
bit about today we know that you got a
really big advantage oh where where did
it go wrong uh I think it was probably
winning at some point I his position
looked looked like a disaster um maybe
Queen CT was inaccurate I probably made
a couple of inaccuracies and he defended
well and at some point that bed she
slipped away I mean it just kept getting
increasingly more difficult and at some
point it was it was already at all today
we've been asking everybody if you had
to play a tournament with the same
opening and both colors all tournament
against these guys what opening would
you pay um yeah it seems to be the night
or if they were playing but I don't
think I'd pick it the thing is that 110
opening for an entire tournament would
be very boring after a while um but I
seem to be playing the Berlin in most
games these days why is that it's just a
popular opening and so it's very hard to
crack so everyone's playing it and who
do you think is the best at it the best
I have no idea it's you know everyone
studies it a lot and we all have quite a
decent amount of knowledge in the
opening all right Thank You fabiano
karana a draw today again to top to us
players of course we just saw a lot of
them in st. Louis in the rapid and blitz
match and you'll be seeing more of them
in the grand chest door thanks